الهدف هو القوات الروسية وهي
الضفة اليسرى والغطس
والمشاعل لإلهاء صواريخ الباحث الحراري
زوج من المروحيات الأوكرانية في
هجوم ضد القوات الروسية بالقرب من
باكموت
ثم نذهب يجب أن نطير على ارتفاع منخفض جدًا
وسرعة منخفضة جدًا
إلى  منع لمنع التعرف على
الخنادق أدناه والقرويين في
شرق أوكرانيا الذين حطمتهم
الحرب وعادوا
من هذه الطلعة الجوية ، هذه القاعدة الأمامية
سرية بقدر الإمكان.
هذا الصباح ، هل كنت خائفًا ،
تفضل
جيدًا لأن الروس يريدون قتلك ،
فليس لديك أي خيار آخر سوى
القتال مع روسيا
إذا كنت تخاف من البقاء في المنزل ،
فهذا ليس خيارًا هنا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
أريد أن أطير  حرفيا تحت
ارتفاع الأشجار التي تتسلق وتغطس
مع كل قطعة من Woodland التي
نمررها تم
بناؤها على أنها طائرات نقل ، فإنهم أكثر عرضة
للخطر عندما يتسلقون لإطلاق
صواريخهم وهم
يغوصون للغطس على ارتفاع 20 قدمًا فوق
سطح الأرض ، وهو أيضًا تغيير محفوف بالمخاطر
في الصوت  يشير إلى
ضربة شجرة من ريش المروحية في
القاعدة ، يتم تبديل الشفرات
بسرعة.
الأشخاص الذين كنت
أعرف أن أصدقائهم قد ماتوا بالفعل ،
للأسف ، إنه أمر مؤلم للغاية وأنا
مستاء للغاية ولا يمكنني الانتقال
إليك ، واصلنا نحتاج إلى
طائرات جديدة من طائرات الهليكوبتر الهجومية الجديدة للأسف
معداتنا قديمة ومداها
صغير جدًا وغير دقيق
لمدة عام  في محاربة الغزو الروسي
لا تزال أوكرانيا تطلب المزيد من
المروحيات والطائرات النفاثة الأكثر تقدمًا حتى الآن ،
كان رد حلفائها آسفًا
ولكن لا ، لذا يقاتلون هنا مع
ما لديهم
سام كيلي سي إن إن شرق أوكرانيا